you smell alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the day show now everybody
nowadays is on Facebook Twitter tweeting
away and you know as Muslims those who
are submitted to the will of God we're
called to be the best human beings
possible to be in a constant state of
self-development now with all the social
media madness how are we supposed to be
conducting ourselves out there you see a
lot of bad things on the internet and we
need to filter out some of these things
we're having some bad interactions we
might not say it in person when we see
someone but now we're being many people
when they come trolls saying bad things
criticizing people in the wrong way and
you have some brothers also posting
nudity it's scandalous stuff crazy so
we're talking about all this and more so
we can protect ourselves and we can be
right with Allah with our Creator we'll
be right back with this exciting show
with my next guest Omar Suleiman here on
the D show
this is the back here on the deep so
with my special guest Sheikh Omar
Suleiman how are you she hummed a little
hundred lights you know so many great
things to be grateful for our aren't
theirs I mean we when you meet a Muslim
he could be having the worst day but he
always say it hamdulillah how's your day
going and why is this before we get into
our main top why is this why is this you
don't you don't I mean it's like you
know people usually what I'll do is
people say how you doing - thank God
good thank God thank God but to the
average person you know or will
translate you know will say God willing
will say thank God but this is we you
don't find people who are more conscious
of God than those who submit to the will
of God Muslims you know why is why do we
have this well there's always something
to be grateful for right yeah just the
ability to say it hundred enough to say
think thanks to God is a blessing for
which you should thank God so there's
always a reason to say hum did enough
now now you said something before you
said just for Allah giving you the
ability to say hamdulillah and and if
you died on that you thankful -
absolutely I know one of one of the the
scholars of Islam he said that if a lot
of lets you die saying alhamdulillah
then you still owe a lot and hum did a
lot for the other hum did enough you owe
him a thanks for letting you thank him
see I'm benefiting from you I've heard
this I've heard you say - before
masha'Allah so tell us now
you know we talked about the the madness
is out there
you know in the beginning you know the
social media you see it can be used for
a lot of good but you have a lot of
things out there that are bad and it
affects you know what your I see a lot
of times it comes in as a poison and
affects
the heart and a lot of times Muslims
they fall into sending out bad things
getting on a viral train and can you
actually be incurring sin bad deeds by
posting something let's say a woman
who's who's scantily dressed you know
who's you know you're not protecting her
on her but she's she's not protecting
herself and you're posting something
that is showing her just naked and
you're passing it along or you're saying
something foul your pet out there you
see all of this stuff don't you there's
a lot of issues yeah a few things number
one what you used to be able to just as
recently as 20 years ago what you needed
a studio to do now you can do with a
laptop right yeah so people can put
videos out there people can put certain
pictures out there and things of that
sort and you have instant access to the
world people that you might never meet
in your life and so there are people
that are just addicted I think the first
thing to talk about honestly with social
media before even getting all that I
think the most neglected aspect of
social media is that it pollutes your
mind and it teaches you in patience it
teaches you to waste time right and
wasting time as you know one of the
great stars abandoned fame rahim allah
allah have mercy upon him he said
wasting time is worse than death because
death disconnects you from the world
where I was wasting time disconnects you
from Allah so time is a great blessing
and you know a lot of times you know I
know mashallah you know how to do you're
big on jujitsu and stuff like that you
know you go out there you work out you
exercise you play basketball you play
football and we were growing up and our
generation it was that it was workout
exercise play basketball you know do
what you got to do I don't know if
anyone took it as far as you did but the
point is is that living life okay
actually living life and they have the
same online off life and I fully believe
in that that people are just addicted to
their devices you know you'll see you'll
have a 13 year old kid whose parents
will tell them go outside and ride your
bike and you'll say it's hot outside we
would have never said that growing up
it's hot outside right you go out there
and you play okay so the point is is
that people are addicted to these
devices and also one of the things the
Prophet peace be upon him said he said
an agile item in a shape on haste is
from the devil hastiness and rush is
from the devil
and we're being taught to be impatient
your internet you know you remember
dial-up internet you know I still have
my AOL email address and people make fun
of me all the time my first email
address dial-up internet it takes time
now people are impatient that the page
is loading too slow
this isn't coming up this isn't coming
up so people have this impatience and
they've got a comments on it on
something really fast they've got to
share something really fast they've got
to put their opinion on something really
fast people are you know there's so many
process he's going on that you don't
have time to really think things through
anymore so you're acting without
thinking and you're living without
really living and so obviously that
opens the gateway to sin and it opens
the gateway to shape on you know the
devil to advertise certain things to you
to market certain things to you so
you'll see a lot of times with these
what will happen is they'll say you know
guess what she wore to the Emmys click
guess what this person wore click write
guess what she said about what she wore
click is this
it's just sucking UN more and more and
more and more and more so the first
thing we need to recognize again is the
waste of time and the impatience that it
teaches us the hastiness that it teaches
us and how we're not allowed to really
we don't really get a chance to process
things and think about what we're doing
anymore before we do them and then
obviously the lack of modesty the
Prophet peace be upon him if you look at
all of the signs of the Day of Judgment
the vast majority of them are lack of
modesty is the disappearance of modesty
and what is you know online you know you
post things you know ask people all the
time you know people ask me is it oh is
it permissible to put this picture
online and I tell them if you would be
comfortable posing in front of a person
in real life in the same pose that you
put up online which conveys you know
there is there is something on TED talks
that I couldn't I really can't spread
because there are certain images but
this lady was talking about what images
really convey and how a lot of you know
the posing of lingerie models and women
and things of that sort and these and
these shoots these photo shoots is I'm
available there are multiples of me
right I'm all yours so if you would have
that if you'd be willing to pose in
front of a person in real life with that
same pose then by all means go ahead and
put it up right and at the same time we
don't recognize
what the we have no idea who accesses
these pictures who gets ahold of them
I've seen I've seen a person you know
I've walked in mistakenly into a room of
her brother one time where he had the
profile picture of a Muslim sister
blowing up and hanging hanging on his
wall all right you have no clue what
people are doing with your pictures and
obviously again the lack of modesty in
regards to how you how you what you
write online so I tell people all the
time I say look if you wouldn't say it
to a person in real life then don't say
it online so I meet people for example
you know who draw at me on you know
trolls on Facebook and Twitter on social
media they say terrible things then you
meet them in person they're kind polite
it's like it's teaching you split
personality so if you wouldn't say it in
real life then don't say it online as
well okay so just people living
vicariously through these these these
illusionary you know mediums of social
media whatever you want to call them in
and it's really concerning and it really
does enhance the lack of modesty that
the prophet peace be upon him told us
about and what we say and what we
portray and what we share of what others
post as well we're gonna go ahead and
take a break and then we got some more
really important questions to ask you
on this very very important topic here
on the deen shall we write back please
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show so the brother
says look I didn't take the picture over
and he says what's wrong with sending it
just like sending it just like the guy
says look I'm not drinking the alcohol
so he sells it in his shop right so have
you heard these excuses what do you
respond to that how do you strum that so
there's a big enough problem when you
see something wrong and you don't say
anything about it so the Prophet peace
be upon him he said that on the day of
judgment a man would be raised and
actually the full context of the hadith
is actually and it fits into what we
spoke about with advice in the previous
episode now yeah that I had to come
enough said let not one of you belittle
himself so the companion said how do we
belittle ourselves the Prophet peace be
upon him said that you see an evil that
you should speak about but you don't say
anything and then on the day of judgment
Allah
you and you say and Allah says to you
why didn't you say anything and you say
oh my lord
I say to NAS I was afraid of people and
Allah says Allah was more deserving of
being feared so it's bad enough the
Prophet peace be upon him said you're a
mute devil a silent devil when you see
people doing evil and you don't say
anything about it okay now what's worse
than that is when you encourage them to
sin then you're not a silent devil then
you are actually a Shaitaan you're
actually a devil so you invite by your
sharing for example of that photo or
that video or commenting in a positive
way you know so sister for example might
fully be covered in a modest way but she
sees another sister that's posing in a
very very inappropriate way and you know
she posts online sis you look so
beautiful and and praises her picture
basically so you're praising her and
you're encouraging her to keep on doing
that our brother might see someone post
a lewd picture as well because a lot of
times we think modesty is only for the
women mm-hmm it always blows my mind
when you have a brother that's topless
on on Facebook and wearing shorts and
stuff like that you know taking a
picture on the beach and he's going off
on a sister for not wearing hijab I was
like brother you've got to wear a hijab
- mm-hmm you have modesty as well you
know what happened to that whole concept
of haya
modesty for men as well the Prophet
peace be upon him was described as being
more bashful that you know than the
shyest virgin if you will right he was
extremely bash watery his thoughtless
not very shy so the point is is that you
know you're not when you're praising
other people when they do wrong and then
sharing it so that perhaps you know I
would have gone online I wouldn't have
seen that evil but because you shared it
now I see it then you are just like the
one who committed the sin in the first
place because we believe in Islam and
residual good deeds and in residual sins
you leave behind a legacy either a
positive legacy or a negative legacy a
dad or unemployed coverity the Prophet
peace be upon him he said the one who
guides to good is like the one who does
the good in the first place and by
analogy the one who guides to evil is
like the one who did evil in the first
place so when you share it and you
praise it then you are as evil as that
person and as that thing which is being
portrayed by that person so technically
now you press send and you have a
scantily man or woman now other people
see it because now you're their friend
you can actually end up incurring the
bad deed as long is as being sent is
that right absolutely you know there's a
horrific story that that I'll share with
you that you know obviously before
pornography became as available as this
today when the internet when internet
pornography first came out there's a
Sheikh Mohammed denied anything who
tells the story online actually there
was a young man who got a pornography
subscription online and he told his
friend you know in order to get popular
and a lot of times we send to be popular
because it's cool a lot of peer pressure
right so he told his friends look give
me your email addresses enough forward
you that pornography you know every time
I get that so get that next batch and he
died at the age of 19 as a young man
tragic death all of a sudden died in the
car accident the woman - no time to play
around and then the day that they prayed
and I was on him those men went home his
friends went home and they still got
that pornography in their email and they
continued to get that pornography
because he had it on autoscent somehow
Allah I mean it's amazing that's his
legacy right just Auto and they tried to
contact the web site they tried to stop
it they couldn't stop it as the
subscription for was for an entire year
that entire group of people was
constantly getting pornography sent to
their email from that young man's
address even though he was dead so
that's you want to you want something
positive to outlast you and you want to
invite people to good and not to evil as
opposed to right now you finish watching
this program and then you actually send
this program and let's say I might miss
someone's life a million people get to
see it or even if just your intention by
sending it maybe even they watch a
minute or it changes someone life you
will get those good deeds even better
maybe someone takes your Hado mm-hm and
they get the same reward as you do that
Steve and as they press there that's how
you get rich with the law but the other
way you're incurring on the anger of
your Creator
pleasure look everything can be used for
good or evil mm-hmm
they're written about the scars they
always give the example of even
prostration you could prostrate to a lot
which is the ultimate sign of submission
to God or you could prostrate to devil
which is to the shape on the devil which
is the ultimate sign of rebellion
everything can be used for good or evil
social media is a powerful tool and if
time that's not all that I mean look
what we're able to do on social media
and the people were able to reach and
the way that that Islamic events and
projects and videos get shared and
have-nots it's beautiful it's amazing so
we have to we have to teach ourselves
inshallah taught as a Muslim community
and as as God conscious people to be to
be productive with our social media not
to not to let us not to let it render us
unproductive and even worse sinful has
it happened to you where you have got
invited to a friend's page or you've
seen someone that you might know from
the Masjid and you go on and then you
somehow went on their page and then you
just like start Oh like I can't believe
this is being put out here have you seen
that how many times what I mean I
remember you know I go to an event or I
go to even like some of the youth and my
mother's right when when Facebook first
came out and they were inviting me to be
their friends and I'm accepting their
friends and the profile picture is done
at a bar mm-hmm you know hanging out
with I'm like man I really don't want to
see your profile I'd rather maintain a
high opinion of you and I'll tell you a
secret
honestly personally it's not a secret
anymore I personally don't have a
personal page on Facebook anymore
because I don't want to have a news feed
I don't want to see what anyone else is
doing anymore because I it prevented me
from having a good opinion of certain
people and I didn't want that because I
don't want to think lo of my brother's
sister I want to maintain that high
opinion of them I don't want a lot to
question me for thinking I'm better than
them and I don't want to feel like I'm
better than that so I don't want to
expose myself to their sins so if you
get a private page by the way of almost
of the amount it's a scam especially if
they're asking for money to a bank
account in Nigeria and they Paul or
whatever I've had a lot of those going
on so so now if someone says look
brother I mean everybody's just doing it
I mean you got 99% of the people out
there who are posting you know these
things it's all in in essence of fun
it's a laugh it's not a big deal I'm not
hurting nobody
Allah says
and well until tarakasura knows if you
follow the majority of people you look
on sir we do not
they will divert you they will lead you
astray from the path of Allah we're
always in the minority the people
successful people are always whether
it's in the worldly sense or in the
sense of religion they're always the few
alright so it's only the strong and the
few that survive and you know we have to
consider ourselves to be strangers
that's what the Prophet peace be upon
him said be in this world as if you're a
stranger there is no way that you can
possibly be a Muslim a practicing Muslim
without being socially awkward in some
way and what that translates into and so
in the social media around the realm of
social media is social media awkwardness
as well when other people are all
talking about something commenting on
something sharing a video things are
going viral and you take a back seat and
you say wait a minute you know in a
polite way again I don't want anyone to
become a troll we don't encourage that
because you know and I think we should
talk about that so after the break but I
mean we don't want to encourage people
to become trolls and like be hateful
when they correct because that that
leads to a greater evil but at the same
time you have to be that that strange
person sometimes that person who says
I'm not okay with this and this is
different and this is not something I'm
willing to do so it's different in a
good way because this difference is
keeping us away from the bad things that
have negative side effects yeah but the
good that we do and please in our
Creator everything is good and there's
no negative side effects absolutely
beautiful we right back with more to
wrap it up here on the Deen show please
subscribe to the DCO follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and social media
responsibility being responsible knowing
that there is no time when your Creator
doesn't see you right a loss sees us at
all times he's all-seeing into all
hearing but now this person he's Iman
went a little bit low because they've
been you know fueling it with the wrong
stuff and then he also sees a billboard
it says look there probably isn't a God
so just go ahead and enjoy life what do
you say to this person
well I mean obviously look you know if
you don't fear a lot in public you're
not gonna fear him in private so you
know being conscious of allah is
extremely important you know I'll give
you this example especially with what we
look at online Allah says in the and
yeah animal ha in the denying Allah
knows how in a third Arion which means
Allah knows the fraud of the eyes the
betrayal of the eyes well not so for
solution and that which is hidden in the
hearts of the love and I best me Allah
be pleased with him he said that what
that means is that you see someone in
front of you right so you see a sister
for example but she shouldn't be staring
at and so you know that she sees you so
you put your head down but as soon as
she walks away and she doesn't know that
you're looking anymore you stare okay
now the way I see that now is that you
know in public for example you see a
this especially for the more practicing
Muslims right you see a sister you see a
brother you see something that you
shouldn't be really looking at and you
put your head down because you know
other people see you but then you go
online and that same sister that you
were lowering your gaze from in person
you're looking at a profile picture
you're going through a photos it's
creepy it's it's really really strange
and creepy and awkward so fear a lot in
your public life and in your private
life to fear Allah only in your private
only in your public life is hypocrisy to
not fear Allah in your private life or
in your public life is satanic it's even
worse okay
so a person should strive to fear Allah
and be conscious of God and aware of God
and their private and public lives just
in short before I go to my next question
the the I know this is a topic on its
own but the motivation that we get I
mean obviously is to please our Creator
before we meet up and then the rewards
I mean of paradise you know people get
mode I get motivated knowing that at the
end there's light at the end of the
tunnel you got gentleness fears forever
and now I mean obviously if you read the
Quran Hellfire is mentioned constantly
along with the good news of paradise so
can you briefly just you know touch
about let me give you this really scary
hadith that I think I'm not often when I
when I look at social media the Prophet
peace be upon him said that a man will
come on the day of judgment with his
prayer with his a calf with his fasting
with all of his acts of worship when I
can send Ahava we're shuttin Mohammed
without behind a little Bajada but he
cursed this person he insulted this
person he backed bited this person he
hit this person so the prophet peace be
upon him says all of those people line
up and one by one they take all of his
good deeds until he's left with no good
deeds this is an adult that's prayed his
entire life fasted his entire life later
to Kadir write everything they take all
of his good deeds later to cut the cord
Hyrum Elfie Shah who later took all that
along the night of power is better than
than a thousand months of worship gone
prayer gone Ramadan gone zakah gone and
he says Oh alive got nothing left and
then he started to put their evil on his
back as well why is that so scary how
many people you know don't realize who
they're insulting online who they're
speaking bad about online that person
might be a friend of Allah Willie of
Allah and the prophets lice and I'm said
that Allah has said minute idly what he
ever caught on to about how whoever
hurts one of my friends then I have
waged war on him you might be waging war
on Allah with it with a silly tweet or a
Facebook comment so take that hadith
what how can you know but but instead he
came with his prayer his fasting but he
tweeted at this person he commented on
this person's status with these words he
said this he did that you don't know who
you're insulting you don't know who
you're offending you don't know who
you're hurting you might see one of
those people on the day of judgement and
they come to you to take your good deeds
and you don't even know who they are
because the only thing you've ever seen
of them is a facebook profile picture
you have to be very very careful online
and so if the tongue as the Prophet
peace be upon him taught that nothing
causes a person to fall on you know fall
flat on his face and Hellfire like his
tongue because of what he expresses and
says and does with it
and imagine your keyboard and your phone
and what you write online so really you
know how how foolish would you feel on
the day of judgment if Facebook was the
reason you went to hell how foolish
would you feel if it was just a dumb
comment that I posted online or
something I tweeted out or something I
shared how foolish would we feel on that
day what would be the level of hasla
remorse that Allah speaks about
the people of hellfire if it was just
something so silly on the other hand how
good would you feel on the day of
judgement if you were one good deed
shorts and then it was something good
that you said online something good that
you shared online a person that again
took Shahada because of a dour program
you shared online or something good that
you posted and that that good deed is
the reason for your entrance into
paradise so good character good hook is
to be expressed online in person because
it will be the deciding factor after our
theology it would be the DS a deciding
factor in regards to our destination
being Hellfire or paradise and we ask a
lot of grandmas Paradise a lot I mean I
mean so before we go let's give someone
give them something tangible now because
I think it's pretty simple I mean you
posed good stuff things that help people
you invite them you know to goodness
then you're gonna have the reward of
that goodness then obviously you post
something bad but for the person that
has got their moral compass mixed up a
little bit you know give us some
guidelines how does a person know okay
this is good it'll get me the reward and
this old other here is incurring you
know the bad deeds you know I'm really
glad you asked that question because
there are sincere brothers and sisters
that are active online and again look if
you're good looking online you know if
you're good looking in person good
looking behind the camera you can speak
well you know you've got you've got a
certain platform you know you've got
you've got you're in with some channel
or whatever it may be you represent
something unique
you'll have a voice I mean social media
gives a voice to people that quite
frankly shouldn't really have a voice
sometimes there are a lot of good
brothers and sisters that try to put out
a video you know or try to do something
good in the form of comedy in the form
of art and you know demonstrating
uniqueness and and you know the
intention is to demonstrate the identity
of Islam and in the process you know
they do things that they shouldn't do
and unfortunately you have the trolls on
there that go on there and start calling
them catheter and start calling you know
women for example that aren't wearing
hijab properly they'll call them [ __ ]
online and it just disgusts me hoje
Abi's that's like the new thing that I
seen online and so
there's a principle in our religion and
one care la lluvia women care be Mongkok
government evil cannot be changed with a
greater evil and so unfortunately look
you're going to have people that live in
a completely different social context
cultural context they're gonna go online
and they'll see the sister for example
that just became Muslim and she put up
she made a YouTube channel she put up
videos to talk about Islam and a job and
her hijab is not proper and they're
gonna call her names and insults her and
you'll you'll find you know a brother
who's trying to do some comedy and his
comedy is not really appropriate but he
was never really that practicing of a
Muslim anyway in the first place and
people start attacking him now there's a
responsibility of both of them there's
responsibility upon them both number one
this is a sincere advice seriously I I
really mean this before you do anything
that's going to represent your religion
or say anything that's going to
represent your religion that has the
that has the possibility of reaching
thousands of people sometimes even
millions of people consult someone of
knowledge first identically in kuntum
the tournament Allah says ask the people
of knowledge if you don't know any
better ask the people of knowledge
consult take take an imam into
confidence someone who's more
knowledgeable than you someone who's
there's more you know who knows more
about the religion than you take them
into confidence and say what do you
think about this what do you think about
that because otherwise you're going to
make a lot of mistakes and you'll make
mistakes even if you take people of
knowledge in the conference but the
mistakes will be less in that situation
and then you're going to invite these
trolls and then in the process your
arrogance will grow because you will say
don't judge me leave me alone and you
will ignore the things that you could
have actually done better and you will
refuse to acknowledge the mistakes that
you actually made because you don't want
to give more fuel to the trolls and so
you're destroying yourself in the
process and at the same time those
trolls will also destroy themselves in
the process because they will be putting
you down and they will be earning
themselves a ticket to hell fire as well
possibly with that evil tongue and with
that evil speech so everyone loses in
that situation so if you want to do
something good take people knowledge in
the confidence and ask Allah for
sincerity in it more than anything else
ask Allah for sincerity and guidance and
at the same time take the good of the
criticism that comes your way
acknowledge your mistakes acknowledge
your shortcomings don't
defend them just because you're you know
sometimes there's a good project overall
it's a good project but there are some
certain aspects that are concerning and
people attack the entire project because
of those aspects don't defend the entire
project despite those aspects
acknowledge that you messed up in
certain ways and you apologize for them
own up to them and at the same time try
to make your project better and keep on
going and don't be discouraged and we
ask Allah to make us all sincere callers
to his way and some capacity and allow
us to serve his religion whatever
capacity were capable of doing I mean
the last 10 seconds that we have fuel
for the email at your wwm flexkom ILM
fli XCOM hundreds of hours in shallow
tada of syriza's and tough seared in
history practical lessons we can take
for ourselves that's what we need we
need that fuel for the Iman it's the
knowledge thank you very much we start
with peace wedding the peace thank you
alaikum Salaam
and there you have it as the last and
final messenger sent to mankind upon
Muhammad peace be upon him he said
Mandela Allah hiding for a whole myth lo
a GD family the one who invites to good
you invite to good you can never go
wrong and then you're gonna have an
equivalent reward just like the one who
does it that's just simple mathematics
it's easy to comprehend do good you get
good no bad side effects you do bad you
get bad a lot of bad side effects so
make sure that you're posting the right
stuff saying the right words so we can
live a good life and the pleasure of our
Creator so when we die we can avoid the
Hellfire and we can have the pleasure of
our crater we can attain the gender the
paradise because every Messenger of God
call people to worship the Creator not
the creation and they gave the good news
that if you do good you live a good
righteous life you do the things that
are pleasing to your Creator you get the
paradise and the warning if you follow
your desires and you disobey God and you
just run scantly in wild you're gonna
have a lot of bad consequences and then
what you can end up in the Hellfire so
let's avoid the Hellfire let's get to
the judgment of the paradise by being
good doing good and make sure that you
connect with us you were here every week
same time same Channel
until next time until that peace be with
you please subscribe to the DCO follow
us on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below